democratic congresswoman dina titus is  raising the alarm about nuclear waste  that the federal government is storing  right here in town titus asking the  department of energy why her office  wasn't notified about the shipment of  nearly five olympic pools worth of spent  fuel from idaho she says she only  learned about the shipment when reading  stars in stripes magazine  what kind of waste it is or how much it  is or what they're going to do with it  when they get it to the nevada test site  and a member of the nevada delegation  shouldn't have to read it in a magazine  the department of energy should be  communicating with us directly so we  know what's going on  titus says she is also concerned about  what could happen if something went  wrong in transporting the nuclear waste  to nevada this is just the very latest  in an ongoing clash about storing  radioactive material at the nevada  nuclear security site denise